aucun contact sur RFM je connais je
connais bien j'espère y rester dans ma
priori je devrais est-ce qu'ils t'ont
dit que c'était bon oui ça a l'air
d'aller non parce que c'est sûr
tu veux que j'appelle le patron des
référence dans la vie vous savez bien en
revanche animaux ça reprend animaux
c'est sûr bah oui personne ne veut y
aller
mais sans déconner
très belle chaîne
les animaux il y a des collègues et de
cerfs
je vais travailler je fais mes
livraisons avec moi mais où et pourquoi
tu es avec moi d'accord
fin de journée
pour savoir plus sur la soirée qui
s'annonce t'inquiète pas c'est mon ami
on a déjà fait des soirées jacuzzi
ensemble il était dans le jacuzzi il
était dehors
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire exactement pourquoi il
est aussi détendu Guillaume Genton
depuis quelques temps avant quand on lui
parlait de meuf tout ça il était un peu
à ça et tu vas me dire si c'est la
vérité ou pas ce que je veux dire
Guillaume j'attends je le connais je
suis sûr il a dû avoir une discussion
avec sa meuf il a dû dire à sa meuf
ouais tu vois c'est le chaud
arrête de prendre la tête avec ça
attention mais bien sûr donc voilà
attends c'est normal que je fasse le
chaud avec Cyril donc bien sûr c'est que
je suis des meufs c'est la télé j'arrête
sinon j'arrête c'était pas capable de
faire des câlins
d'assumer je vais être avec une star de
la télévision
je vais reprendre la cordonnerie en face
et puis on sera très bien franchement
franchement oui tu mets des masqué ma
couille
tu peux mettre dans la même voiture
c'est une bonne technique c'est vous qui
me l'avez prise d'ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
on trouve encore des citrouilles